Hey guys, I'm out of the hot springs  today because we're trying an experiment today using dry ice. So crazy Russian hacker
Just posted a video on the internet throwing 30 pounds of dry ice into a swimming pool, and it made a really cool effect
So got me thinking. I went to the store and cleaned them out, and I just picked up 200 pounds of dry ice
So I brought my family out to the hot springs today because as far as I know
nobody has ever tried throwing dry ice into the hot springs
I need a little bit of help today, so I enlisted my buddy Jeremy to come out
He's going to be our guinea pig
And we're gonna get started by smashing up all this dry ice and throwing it in a bucket
And then we're gonna toss a hundred pounds of dry ice into a pool with Jeremy in. We really have no idea what to expect here
As long as you keep moving it quickly
There's not enough time for it to frostbite your fingers, but you don't want to grab on to the stuff for very long
It is cold!
Now the more we can break up this dry ice the quicker it's going to react with the water because there's going to be more
Surface area
The bottom of our bin is cracking and the dry ice is falling out. That's how cold it is.
Oh wow, that's amazing!
Have you ever seen anything like this before?
The whole bottom fell out of that bucket
That's completely destroyed
This is the bucket
I used to throw the dry ice, but it got so cold on the bottom that the plastic completely shattered. How crazy is that?
Jeremy, how long has it been gone?
Okay, guys. I can't believe this
We're pushing seven minutes and it's still going strong. This water is so hot, i can't believe that dry ice is lasting.
You can see how thick that fog still is
Now a block of dry ice like this is solid carbon dioxide. When it hits the water, it heats up and the carbon dioxide
vaporizes and goes back into the atmosphere
the moisture in the Air is getting so cold that it's
Condensing and turning back into a cloud, and that's what the vapor is that you're seeing here.
What kind of sorcery is this?
We've actually got some remnants of the dry ice down here
May as well throw that in. Oh, my little boy just threw one into this pool. That's cool. We found the secret Stash
Okay, we're gonna do one more shot into this pool back here and see how that looks
Jeremy is this what you expected to be doing today?
Beats having a real job. Doesn't it?
So this is seriously awesome guys. Perfect day to be doing this experiment with all the steam coming off
It looks like it'd be minus 52 below, but it's not it's more like eighty five. We're loving it
Wow, you're on TV!
So we used up quite a bit of dry ice. We're down to about our last 40 or 50 pounds
So I'm going to go talk to the staff and see if they'll turn on the water slides for us
Maybe we can take these bad boys for a ride
Where did you go?